today on the matt welsh show fox news
airs far left extreme trans propaganda
what is going on over at fox and how
should we respond we'll talk about it
also democrats and republicans in the
senate agree on their new gun control
plan which includes red flag laws what
could possibly go wrong with red flag
laws all explained plus justin trudeau
announces that canadians no longer have
a right to self-protection his words
exactly in our daily cancellation
rolling stone publishes a hit piece on
my film what is a woman but did the
writer of the piece actually watch the
movie the answer will shock you no it
won't but we'll talk about it all that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know you might be thinking there's
no relief or help coming at the pump for
us and that's certainly the case you
know if you uh if you're asking waiting
for joe biden to help you out but there
is an incredible app that can give you
some relief it's called upside my
listeners are earning cash back for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download the free upside app in
the app store google play right now use
promo code walls for 25 cents per gallon
or more on your first fill up cash back
don't pay full price to pump anymore get
cash back using upside just download the
app for free and use promo code walsh
for 25 cents per gallon or more
on your first tank and it's not just for
gas by the way you can earn cash back at
grocery stores restaurants take out many
different areas you can cash out anytime
to your bank account or an e-gift card
for select retailers and brands just
download the app for free it's the
upside app use promo code walsh to get
25 cents per gallon or more cash back on
your first tank um and this again this
is uh this is you got the pump you're
spending all this money on gas
and uh you're waiting for the prices to
go back down that's probably not gonna
happen anytime soon especially as we get
into the summer that you can earn cash
back
with the upside app just use promo code
walsh now that's code walsh
cities all across the country held their
pride marches this weekend pride marches
are of course events made for and by
people who just want to be left alone
and who simply want to be able to love
each other and who really truly only
want privacy and um whose sex lives are
just none of our business and their way
of communicating those feelings to us is
to prance down the street in bondage
gear and assless chaps and twerk in
front of crowds of strangers including
children
you know that's that's that's their way
of communicating their sex lives are so
private and so completely none of our
business
that they throw parades nationwide to
advertise and celebrate their sex lives
this is obviously what anyone would do
when they want something to be private
it's why um you know i've published my
email password on a times square
billboard because i don't want anyone to
see it and so that's what you do when
you want something to be private you
just show everybody
seems like the best strategy and that's
why a half naked guy in drag might
might shout you know mind your own
business as he dry humps the pavement in
the middle of the street at two o'clock
in the afternoon
when we're expected to ignore the
contradiction we're also expected to
ignore all the many ways in which
children are directly and intentionally
involved in this sort of thing there
were many videos circulating on social
media this weekend of kids very young
kids toddlers in some cases standing
along these parade routes with their
abusive parents
and the kids always look simultaneously
confused bored and traumatized by what
they're witnessing at a pride parade in
california
two little girls could be seen watching
with befuddled expressions as a morbidly
obese drag queen uh rolled by on a
rainbow pride float
while shouting about lube into a
megaphone
watch
[Music]
[Applause]
bandanas and lube i think uh
ursula said there up on the float
it it could be worse i mean they could
have been forced to witness a group of
men in bondage gear with their asses
exposed whipping each other as they
walked down the street that's the
hideous sight that one toddler was
subjected to here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
there's that little kid is what uh looks
like he's two three years old
and look at his mom his mom is there
she's so proud
she wants she's taking a picture she
wants to get her toddler
and the guys in bondage gear in the same
picture together she's trying to get the
right angle
now let me correct myself these two
videos were taken at the same pride
parade i believe so the little girls who
saw the fat drag queen shouting about
lube also probably had to see the
bondage clap groom clad groomers acting
out their sexual fetishes in front of
the public
as i said there are many videos like
this i can't play most of them on this
show especially the footage
that made the rounds of a topless trans
person in a thong bending over and
twerking in front of a crowd that once
again included small children i'll just
leave that up to your imagination though
you probably would prefer not to imagine
it now leftists as we know are
determined to induct children into the
lgbt cult as early as possible and by
any means at their disposal
that's why we must be totally determined
and dedicated
to protecting children from this abuse
and that's also all the more reason why
it was so dispiriting and uh really
frankly tragic on friday a day before
the sodom and gomorrah festivities
kicked off to see fox news
jump on the lgbt grooming bandwagon
actually fox didn't just join the
bandwagon they skipped all the way to
the front of it they ran out in front of
the bandwagon so they could be you know
leading it
during their america's newsroom
broadcast fox ran a package by reporter
brian yanus
promoting and celebrating the transing
of children they were not this was not a
report reporting on this
controversy
but uh no celebrating promoting it
actively
the propaganda was so radical so far to
the left
that i would have honestly been
surprised to see it on cnn
or even msnbc
but even those outlets have not quite
gone as far to the left on the trans
issue as fox apparently has at least
with this report
that's how bad it is
it's certainly bad enough that i have to
call them out i appear on fox news often
i've benefited from the platform from
the visibility that they've given me
it's quite possible that by attacking
them publicly i've now ruined that
relationship so be it in that case
they really left us no choice
the segment was that bad
but don't take my word for it let's go
let's go through this and kind of watch
it together uh just so we can see how
bad this really is here it is walking
down the street
you wouldn't
think anything different
fourteen-year-old ryland whittington is
a typical southern california teenager
and the whittingtons along with mom
hillary dad jeff and sister brinley are
a typical family the only difference
though in ryland's eyes is what this
family can mean to the tens of thousands
of kids under 18 who identify as
transgender we put our story out there
so people could
see that like there's another family out
there that
is
going through what we're going through
or there's another family who's proud of
who they are before rylan could even
speak he managed to tell his parents
that he is a boy i could just see it it
wasn't him trying to be
a brat it was like painful it was truly
painful for him to have to wear feminine
clothing and and for us constantly
telling him that you're a girl and
unlike some trans kids when ryland came
out at age five a few years later he had
the full support of his parents
before the girl could speak
she was communicating that she's a boy
before she could speak
fox wants us to believe that babies can
choose their own gender
children so young that they they don't
yet have the ability to communicate in
words
can still according to fox consent to
begin a gender transition and on what
basis
where is the evidence for this
wild assertion
how do we know that babies have a
concept of quote unquote gender identity
well because because here's why because
this baby didn't want to wear dresses
that's it that's the whole story
and that's the whole sword they didn't
want to orgasm by this logic of course
almost every baby girl is really a boy
there are no girls left in the world it
turns out because almost every young
girl in the world and that has ever
existed in the world has gone through at
least a phase
where they didn't want to wear the
clothes their parents put them in every
boy has also gone through this phase
so maybe every boy is really a girl and
every girl is really a boy we'll just
we'll just trade places make it simple
there are no girls left in the world
except boys the only girls left in the
world are boys and the only boys left
are girls
this is the utter irredeemable madness
that flows from the kind of demented
half-baked incomprehensible pseudo-logic
you just heard from fox
never mind the fact that once again
the trans activists
are rigidly enforcing gender roles while
com claiming that they want to break
down gender roles they are rigidly
enforcing them the idea that that the
girl you know just might be a girl who
doesn't like quote unquote girly things
that never even occurs to these parents
or to any trans activist
well she's two years old she doesn't
want to wear a dress maybe she just
doesn't like the
dresses not to mention the fact that the
one dress that we saw there was like
hideously ugly so we could hardly blame
her for not wanting to wear that one
i mean that could be it if your
two-year-old daughter doesn't want to
wear the dress it could just be like she
just is too doesn't want to wear a dress
right now
or or she could really be a boy
oh yeah that must be it she's a boy
so according to the trans activists and
to the left and now to fox news
girls
must like girly things and if they don't
then they're boys
so good news ladies you can be anything
you want to be you have
self-determination
nobody can tell you what to do you are
your own person be yourself
unless you don't like the color pink or
if you prefer not to wear dresses and
then you can't even be a girl anymore
you're now a boy
here's some injections to sterilize you
and permanently alter your voice oh also
have to remove your breasts you're not
gonna be needing those ever in your
whole life we've decided because you
don't like wearing dresses
you don't like wearing dresses so we're
gonna chop your breasts off and you'll
just you'll never have that bodily
function ever again
this is the deranged dangerous insanity
that fox news is selling
and it gets worse listen
initially there was some pushback from
us and trying to understand this we were
confused like most people are we thought
that gender and sexuality were the same
thing it took us a while to figure out
that those two things are different and
that children actually do recognize
their gender identity very young some of
them not all but they listened to rylan
and to hillary's conservative faith for
me it's just a deep spiritual belief
that you believe in god and he you know
created us the way he wanted us well
then yes he created ryland just the way
he is and they listened to families they
met in support groups there was a father
who was sitting across the table he says
you have no idea how lucky you are to be
here which kind of took me back i didn't
at that point consider myself lucky to
be there and he said you know our our
child had displayed
this gender dysphoria or this gender
misalignment at at the same age that
ryland has
and
we didn't listen and we pushed back that
pushback led that child to turn to
self-harm as a teenager which 60 percent
of trans and non-binary kids engaging
according to the trevor project more
than 50 percent consider suicide that
for me was the turning point i didn't
want to see ryland to go through that
i'd rather have a living son than a dead
daughter
like i told you this is actually worse
more radical more extreme than anything
we've heard on msnbc at this point
up to this point on this subject
they're packing all of the most extreme
and nonsensical trans agenda talking
points into one piece of propaganda
we've already heard that a girl chose
her own gender when she was a toddler
and then came out when she was five
that's an actual sentence that was
uttered on the air on fox news
when she came out when she was five
she's been on the earth for only five
years she has almost no understanding of
the world or herself or human biology
she not gonna be a legal adult for
another 13 years her brain won't be
fully developed for another 20 years
and yet she was able to make this
decision for herself
and then we're told that the parents
conservative faith is what drove them
mommy munchausen says that god doesn't
make mistakes and she's right about that
yet her conviction that god doesn't make
mistakes is what led her to the
conclusion that her daughter was born in
the wrong body
and was really supposed to be her son
and the only way to fix it is with drugs
and surgery
on the contrary it turns out that
according to her god does make mistakes
he makes pretty big ones it turns out
there are some major screw-ups on the
heavenly assembly line and somehow boy
souls are put into girl bodies and vice
versa
and this seems to be happening a lot
more recently too somehow
must be a new management up at the
factory probably should review their
training protocols i don't know
no by mommy uh munchausen's telling
god is a bumbling fool
an idiot
whose work needs to be checked and
corrected with the help of the
pharmaceutical industry that's what she
thinks
next we're given a few alleged facts and
figures from the far left propagandist
organization the trevor project which
claims that alleged trans kids will kill
themselves if they're not allowed to
transition their gender
i'd rather have a living son than a dead
daughter mommy munchausen tells us
this is the macabre bumper sticker
slogan that has served to justify the
butchery of thousands of children's
children there's no data to back it up
nothing
in fact as we discussed last week the
data shows that gender transition
does not decrease the suicide rate
in fact the data shows that it increases
it
suicidality is highest a decade after
transition that's what the data shows
the suicide claim from trans activists
is nothing but emotional blackmail
in the case of these horrendous evil
parents it's simply a rationale it's
self-justification to legitimize their
choices after the fact
speaking of legitimizing choices after
the fact
nobody at fox has explained how this
toxic nonsense ended up on the airwaves
i know for a fact that many of the
people who work at fox do not agree with
this
do not want to be associated with it
but a decision was made by somebody to
do this report and air it
all the parties involved should explain
themselves and then they should be fired
also
oh are you promoting cancel culture you
want to cancel these people absolutely i
want to cancel them yes
they should be fired for sure named
shamed and fired
when you put dishonest
trans you know militant trans propaganda
on the airwaves
that's going to do and is doing
immeasurable harm to thousands of kids
then yeah you should be fired for that
fox speaks largely to a conservative
audience and nobody in the audience
wants any part of this
of all the people that were watching fox
on that friday when that than when that
report aired
how many of them wanted that
so this is propaganda made by and for an
audience that doesn't watch fox and
hates fox
and especially hates fox's actual
audience
but forget about conservative for a
moment okay put that aside
if fox news wants to call itself news
then it cannot put insane falsehoods and
radical far left lies and propaganda on
the air if you want to be a news
organization
especially this kind of propaganda worst
of all
propaganda which aims to exploit and
destroy children
so
fox's audience has to call the network
to account
i mean nothing less than a full
retraction an apology should be accepted
here
it's up to the audience to demand that
so the audience can decide whether they
just want to let this slide
as fox news celebrates pride month
putting up trans propaganda that again
would not be aired by any other major
network on tv right now
a lot of them would go close to what you
just saw from fox but they wouldn't even
go that far
suggesting that a toddler can choose her
own gender
when you hear that from the left but
even on cnn they would say ah it's a
little too far
maybe in a year or two we'll we'll be at
a point where we can put that out there
and not have any blowback
now fox's audience should have zero
tolerance policy
for propaganda of any kind especially
trans propaganda
and you need to make sure that fox gets
that memo
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so far there's been over 400 recorded
recorded data compromises that have
happened in 2022 okay that's 400 that's
a big number if you didn't know this is
an increase of 14 from last year
impacting more than 20 million americans
some of the most lucrative pieces of
data cyber thieves want to steal are
social security numbers gmail login and
passwords even driver's licenses
uh and that's why it's so important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives and they
are affecting our lives every day your
personal information gets exposed so
often making it dangerously easy for a
cyber criminal to steal your identity
protecting your identity then has never
been more important but it also has
never been easier than it is now with
lifelock by norton lifelock detects and
alerts you to potential identity threats
like your
things that you might not be able to
spot on your own if your social security
number is for sale in the dark web
things like that and if you do become a
victim of identity theft a dedicated
us-based restoration specialist will
work to help you fix it nobody can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
it's easy to help protect yourself with
lifelock by nordon identity theft
protection starts here join now and save
25 off your first year at lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh for 25
off
well since we're on the subject of the
of betrayals i think this is a good
segue here this is from the daily wires
as a bipartisan group of u.s senators
announced sunday that they had agreed to
a framework to implement new gun control
measures following the tragedy in uvalde
texas
late last month the group of 20 senators
said in a statement
say we're announcing a common-sense
bipartisan proposal to protect america's
children keep our schools safe and
reduce the threat of violence across our
country our plan increases needed mental
health resources improves school safety
and support for students and helps
ensure dangerous criminals and those who
are
educated as mentally ill adjudicated
rather can can't purchase weapons and
then there are nine points of focus
they're saying in this this proposed
legislation
and we go through the nine points
the first one is support for state
crisis intervention orders um and that's
provides resources to states and tribes
to create and administer laws that help
ensure deadly weapons are kept out of
the hands of individuals whom a court
has determined to be a significant
danger to themselves or others
consistent with state and federal due
process and constitutional protections
so that's red flag laws in other words
that's what those are
um and then they say they're going to
invest in children and family mental
health services
they're going to have protections for
domestic victims of domestic violence
funding for school-based mental health
and supportive services
funding for school safety resources and
that says invest in programs to help
institute safety measures in and around
primary and secondary schools
support school violence potential
prevention efforts and provide training
to school personnel and students
and then some study
under 21 enhanced review process for
buyers under 21 years of age requires an
investigative period to review juvenile
and mental health records including
checks with state databases and local
law enforcement so as i go through this
um
penalties for straw purchasing crackdown
on criminals who illegally straw
purchase and traffic guns as i go
through this i'm looking for
first of all
the
measures that would have actually
prevented
the shooting in uvalde taxes or the
buffalo
uh the massacre in buffalo
and i know that the first thing we're
going to be told is that well uh you
know point number one would have
prevented both of those things red flag
laws
right because both of these shooters
were mentally disturbed they had
histories of uh of violence they
they were known to be you know a threat
to themselves and others and yet they
were able to get their hands on weapons
well
the problem is that
in new york they already have red flag
laws
and those laws did nothing
to prevent the shooting in buffalo
so there's really no evidence that these
laws work at all we've we already see
there are already versions of these
kinds of measures in place in many
states across the country and um they
don't appear to be doing very much
by the way it says uh so a bunch of
republicans are on board for this of
course um
and
as i said just another another example
of
betrayal of course from conservatives
you know we
what we have to understand if we don't
already is that
we cannot trust
you know any of these institutional
powers that are supposed to be
representing conservative interests
and as fox news has revealed that's the
case for them and that's the case of
course for
republicans in congress
as for the red flag laws especially i
think there are two really important
points about this
uh the first is that again they don't
work we've already seen at least they
don't work to actually prevent these
kinds of shootings
if they did then buffalo never would
have happened
and yet it did happen
uh and the second point is that
you're giving power over to the state
to determine ahead of time who is uh
you know
who can be trusted
with a firearm and who can't
and that could work i mean that's fine
if you can trust the state
but we know that we can't
so these kinds of measures they're just
begging
to be to be
used
by the left to prevent their ideological
opponents from
getting their hands on weapons
i mean you have to ask like what
qualifies as a red flag
well a red flag means that you're you're
a danger to the public right okay
well on the surface that seems to make
sense
and i would agree that if somebody is
actually a physical danger to the public
then they shouldn't be able to get their
hands on a weapon
like the guy down in uvalde texas
or the shooter in buffalo
in texas he was he was again known to
everybody around him to be to be uh to
be you know mentally unstable
there's videos of him abusing animals
and all this kind of stuff so we have
them on on on video being violent and
everything else
so if that's what you mean by a danger
to the public then uh then sure you know
i think everyone can agree
that you got to do everything you can
within the bounds of the law to stop
actually physically dangerous people
from
acquiring the tools to
you know act out
in this kind of way
but what does the left mean
when they call someone a danger to the
public
remember
for the last two weeks they've been
saying that i i myself yours truly i'm a
danger i'm genocidal
i'm actually guilty of genocide they've
said just for making a movie they don't
like
so we know that this is the um
this is kind of the ground that they've
laid ahead of time
that they've they've established that
you're a danger to the public you're a
physical danger to people's lives
if you have certain opinions
certain viewpoints that they don't like
and if you think i'm exaggerating this
seems like a far-fetched conspiracy
theory they're not going to use red flag
laws to disarm conservatives on
ideological or political grounds they
would never do that that's crazy that's
that that's come on that's conspiracy
theory stuff
well um
there's a tweet from 2000 from 2019
representative eric swalwell it's kind
of making the rounds online again today
responding to
um
and about ben shapiro so
jason campbell over at media matters
back in 2019
tweeted a uh uh
a video of ben shapiro talking about
well he says ben shapiro warns that if
politicians try to mandate lgbtq
indoctrination at all schools then he
will pick up a gun further adding
better o'rourke does not get to raise my
child and if he tries i will meet him at
the door with a gun so obviously media
matters doing their thing taking a a
clip from a daily wire
show which this is what they love to do
it's their favorite thing take the clip
take it wildly out of context obviously
ben here is talking about
um you know
oppression by the state tyranny by the
state and how
we can the second amendment exists
to protect us
from tyranny from the state
pretty pretty standard most people
understand that eric swallow responds to
that and says about ben shapiro
please tell me this lunatic does not own
a gun
reason
1578 why america needs red flag laws
so this is a guy in congress who's
already said
that uh if there are red flag laws
federal red flag one of the first people
he wants to disarm is ben shapiro
now i could be i mean i i have i admit i
haven't checked ben's criminal record
but
uh i'm pretty sure that he doesn't have
any felony arrests for any violent
crimes or any other crimes at all
i'm guessing he probably doesn't have
any misdemeanors
so this is based on something that he
said on his podcast that media matters
didn't like and so media matters
highlights this
and then the state comes along and says
up that's a red flag i don't know about
this guy he's a danger
and it doesn't have to be about guns
specifically
as i said my my uh documentary had
nothing to do with guns but it's
genocidal
if you don't if you disagree with
transing five-year-old kids
everything i said to start the show if
you just if you disagree with with that
fox news segment
then you're genocide you're you're a
threat to the public you're causing
suicide you're you're killing p you are
directly killing people
and you don't even have to say anything
silence is also violence keep in mind
so it's a red flag if you say something
they don't like it makes you a danger
and even if you don't say something
where they think you ought to be saying
something
that can also that's violent you could
be killing somebody doing that they say
another red flag
so this is always the problem you run
into with any gun control legislation
and the reasons that they get behind it
before you could even begin to uh take
these proposals seriously and take them
into consideration if you were tempted
to do that you have to start by asking
yourself do i trust these people
whatever it is that they're proposing to
be before we we can even analyze the
pluses and minuses right
do i trust them to enforce this fairly
and objectively
or is this a trojan horse
to try to
you know punish their
political opponents
and in this case they've been very clear
that that's the case
and in other
and there are other gun grabbers who are
even more clear i think if you want to
know what the gun grabbing crowd is
really up to justin trudeau
in an interview last week i think this
is on some kind of podcast
you know he's he comes out and this is
another mask off moment we get a lot of
these from justin trudeau
just just listen to this
and
there are debates and we have a a
culture where the difference is guns can
be used for hunting or for sport
shooting in canada and there's lots of
gun owners and they're mostly lost
respecting and law-abiding
but you can't use a gun for
self-protection in canada that's not a
right that you have in the constitution
or anywhere else if you try and buy a
gun you say it's for self-protection no
you don't get that you get it for
hunting you can get it for sport
shooting take it to the range no problem
as long as you go through our rigorous
background checks but there's a
difference around the culture and one of
the things that we're seeing with the
debate in the states is you get more and
more of the american style you know
right to carry self-defense arguments
filtering up through through the uh you
know the usual more right-wing
communications channels yeah
you don't get to have a gun for
self-defense in canada that's what he
said
once again
if if you had predicted this as a
conservative and many did for years
leading up to this that was a slippery
slope fallacy oh that's ridiculous it's
never going to come to that uh of course
you can use a gun for self-defense
everybody
and now we have justin trudeau
saying no you don't have that right to
use a gun in self-defense
at this uh i don't this is i don't think
an exaggeration to say this is one of
the worst things we've ever heard
a political leader say in the western
world i mean ever
it's one of the most demented and
frankly terrifying things we've ever
heard
from somebody leading a country in the
western world
you don't get to use a gun for
self-defense and he was very clear about
that you don't have that right self you
do not have the right to self protection
to preserve your own life you don't have
that right
who has that right well the state has it
what does that mean the state will
decide
if you're worthy of continuing your
existence or not
and so if you're in canada this is what
justin trudeau is saying this is not me
extrapolating this is what he just said
that if you're in canada and um
you find yourself confronted by a bad
guy with a gun
because the bad guys are still gonna
have them right because the bad guys
they don't care about the law
and you could you could pass 50 laws
saying the same thing over and over
again
you ban guns and then pass another law
banning them again and again and again
and uh you know the thing about the the
law breakers is that they're going to
look at all 50 and just say i don't
care in fact they're quite happy about
it because it just means that
there's going to be less resistance
fewer of the good guys are going to have
guns fewer of the law-abiding citizens
are going to have guns
in fact none of the law-abiding citizens
are going to have guns because by
definition
if you're law abiding then you're biting
this law you don't have a gun
so in canada they're still going there
still are and still will be forever
um criminals with guns and what justin
trudeau is saying is that when the when
the criminal comes up and points a gun
at you and is going to shoot you
it is your responsibility to die
that's your responsibility
to be a good member of the state
to be a good subservient
of the state your responsibility in that
moment is the most noble thing you can
do
is to simply die
and the bad guy with the gun he pointed
at you and tell you i'm going to kill
you
all you can do is just fall to your
knees and say all right well that's it
for me my life is over
your wife and your children are there
too is going to kill your whole family
well
it's then they have to die
that's their responsibility too justin
trudeau is saying
like i said one of the worst things
we've ever heard from a western
political leader one of the worst it's
it's
mind-blowing
even though we expected it even though
we those of us with common sense saw
what he saw where the gun grabbing
uh agenda was headed and we said this
was coming but even so this is the
situation we're in all the time as
conservatives right where we see
something coming we predict it and then
it comes and we're still it still kind
of takes your breath away to actually
see it in real life and hear that
you don't have the right to
self-protection my god
but maybe you'll luck out maybe the cops
maybe an agent of the state will show up
in time to protect you
because why is it the state what's this
all about really
the state
is is what confers the state confers
that right
so when you're confronted by the bad guy
with a gun you yourself inherently don't
necessarily have the right to continue
existing that's not a right that you
have the state confers it
and so if you can call 9-1-1 if you
could tell the bad guy who's about to
shoot you hang on one second let me get
on let me get on the horn call 9-1-1
maybe he'll be nice about it
you know he might be he might be a good
sport and say i'll let you call i'll
give him three minutes to show up they
don't get here in time i'm gonna kill
you you could try that
police show up in
time maybe you can continue existing
of course one of the other uh doctrinal
points in leftism is that the cops are
all
murderous racist bastards
and they are now the ones who are going
to be solely responsible for preserving
and protecting your life this the the
murderous soulless racist bastard so
that's that's that's the way it goes on
the left
all right um a couple other things on
this so there was a a protest over the
weekend
in the united states across the country
this this was in i guess in tandem with
the pride marches so they had the pride
marches going on and the the bdsm guys
with the whips and everything and then
down the street they also had people
marching to end gun violence as their
signs say because that's how you know
that's how you stop gun violence
again going back to the the criminals
with guns the bad guys who are doing all
this um
the next potential mass
shooter you know if he sees the whoever
that is if he sees the march and he sees
somebody holding a sign saying end gun
violence maybe he'll say you know what
you're right this isn't the way to be
drop his gun and be reformed it's
possible
i want to play a little bit of the
reuters report um about this margin dc
because there's a there's a point that i
want to make about it but let's listen
to it
tens of thousands of demonstrators took
part in rallies across the united states
on saturday to demand that lawmakers
pass legislation aimed at curbing gun
violence following last month's massacre
at an elementary school in uvalde texas
in the nation's capital organizers with
march for our lives estimated that 40
000 people assembled at the national
[Applause]
everywhere mall all the time it has been
happening everywhere all the time
because you congress have done nothing
to prevent it
march for our lives the gun safety group
founded by student survivors of the 2018
massacre at a parkland florida high
school said it had planned hundreds of
rallies nationwide for saturday
including in new york city where 9th
grader anya biggs said she believed the
country was close to becoming totally
numb to the violence
i think we're reaching a national
tipping point
especially well i'm in ninth grade but
as i've seen over the past few years the
amount of gun violence that has happened
i think we're reaching a tipping point
where we're about to hit desensitization
to gun violence
okay so we got the ninth grader there
giving her a take on
the direction of society she thinks
we're reaching a tipping point so that's
the point i wanted to make about this
because
especially with these end gun violence
protests march for our lives and
everything um a lot of very young kids
are involved they like to get the young
kids well at least the young kids are
are out in front because they're used
like as political pawns
people actually organizing these events
and um
you know who who
kind of organize these things and and
are actually behind the scenes they're
not kids but they put the kids out front
and center
and especially when it comes to an issue
like this and climate change is the
other one so climate change and gun
violence those are those the two
subjects in particular
where we're supposed to listen to what
the kids are telling us about it
right
and the left says that
um
while also saying that you know of
course kids can choose their own gender
and all the rest of it so this is the
these are the responsibilities that
they're imposing conferring to kids
meanwhile in reality i think i think
those of us in in common sense world
we have a we're pretty consistent about
this
it's like kids are just kids
okay i'm not i'm not too interested
what the declarations a five-year-old
makes about their gender um that doesn't
interest me because that's just a
five-year-old babbling just being a kid
and so let the five-year-old be a kid
doesn't want to wear a dress fine it
doesn't have to wear dress maybe maybe
five years to wear a dress for church
for an hour but that's but that's it
it's fine
um so you let the kid be a kid
and same also for ninth graders who are
marching to end gun violence and are
imparting their wisdom about uh you know
weighing all of that well you've got
second amendment rights versus this and
we're supposed to
listen to what they have to say about it
why
just like listening to a you know a 14
year old tell us about climate change
and all the ways that that human society
has to be reorganized
and we're supposed to listen to
teenagers tell us about that
and take their
ideas seriously
no i don't take their ideas seriously um
because number one i was a teenager once
and i remember it
and number two for their own sake i
don't take them seriously
that is um
a responsibility
that kids shouldn't have like no kid
should be made the front and center of
any movement
at all
that's what being a kid's about
and they don't have the wisdom for it or
the or the ex they have no experience at
all hardly in the world
so because i have common sense and also
for their own sake when i hear kids
going on about any subject i say i
really don't care i don't care what you
think about this it doesn't really make
a difference you don't know what you're
talking about and that's fine i didn't i
didn't either when i was your age
all right one other thing oh i gotta
play this too okay so at the march for
our lives protest there in dc somebody
during one of the speeches apparently
someone yelled out gunshot there was no
gunshot there was no it wasn't even any
loud bang or anything but somebody
yelled out gunshot
and
then here's how the crowd responded
watch this
we fight
every day
okay run it for the exit now look
okay
these are first of all wow these are
very compliant people
um
paranoid on edge very compliant though
because all they they thought that
someone was was shooting and then
the woman on stage says freeze don't run
they all stop it's like a game of simon
says or something maybe that's what was
happening there
but you notice if you're watching the
video and if you're listening on audio
you should go you should go on uh just
on twitter or something and find that
video it's all over the place
but um it's it's quite revealing you
know it illustrates something i think
about this crowd in general
that there are i mean there are
literally like elderly women in in the
back of the crowd near the fence line
somebody yells like gunshot and all of
these younger people are
trampling old women throwing them to the
ground to get away from this phantom
gunshot
which really does kind of tell you
something doesn't it
because they're all there pretending to
you know it's their concern for humanity
for people's lives march for our lives
what they pretend to care about but it's
really my life that they care about
not the life of this old woman because i
i i heard a loud noise and i'm scared
i'm gonna throw her to the ground hop a
fence and i'm out of there
real cowardice on display there all
right um aoc was on
one of the cable news channels doesn't
matter asked about supporting oh so cnn
okay cnn she was asked whether she's
going to support biden's re-election
uh if he does run for reelection and her
answer was
not yes her answer was definitely not
yes let's listen to that
i just want to ask about president biden
he is saying he's going to run again in
2024 will you support him
you know if the president chooses to run
again in 2024 i mean first of all i'm
focused on winning this majority right
now uh and preserving a majority this
year in 2022 so we'll cross that bridge
when we get to it but um but i think if
if the president has a vision and that's
something certainly we're all willing to
entertain and examine when the when the
time comes
that's not a yes
yeah you know i think we should
endorse when we get to it but i i
believe that the president has been
doing a very good job uh so far and um
you know should he run again i think
that i you know i think it's it's
we'll take a look at it
for right now we need to focus on
winning a majority instead of a
presidential election
well that is quite an endorsement i mean
look he's doing a great job and if he
runs again
um we'll
we'll take a look at it we if he runs we
will look at we'll look you know if he
runs we'll look at him running because
that would actually be really that'd be
if he was running that'd be fascinating
to see to see him run
uh because i didn't even know he could
physically do that anymore so if he's
running i'll definitely take a look if
someone's if joe biden was running let
me know and i'll i'll run down there to
see him running
so yeah for sure
she was very she was you know she's not
the smartest uh
smartest person in the world and not the
quickest on her feet so
she's trying to find a way around she
what she didn't want to say was i'd be
happy if he ran again he should run
again
he's doing a great job but i'm not gonna
say that i actually want him to run
again
and of course they don't
uh they they know that this is there's
there's just no way
even the democrats know that
you know facing reality is not their
specialty
but even they realize
this guy is he's gonna turn 80 right
he's turning 80 this year so 2024 he'll
be 82.
he's going to run again and he's going
to have to tell the american people that
yeah i'll be your guy until i'm 86.
even the democrats know it just it can't
happen it's not tenable
i don't make a lot of political
predictions because the few that i do
make are almost always wrong but
uh this is one i've made from the
beginning and i'll and i will reiterate
again there's just there's no way that
this guy he might want to run again but
the democrat party they can't allow it
they know it
they just can't it's not possible
especially when there was a report
yesterday this last week
about um
all indications are that pope francis
is mercifully
thank god looking at retiring which was
actually going to put put the catholic
church in a really unprecedented
position of having two
retired popes
who are now kind of like sitting around
in a in their retirement home
the makings of a really interesting
sitcom or something um
and
so
that's that's he hasn't done it yet
obviously you would have heard about it
but that's the report suggests that pope
francis probably will retire uh just as
pope benedict retired before him
so you've got popes who are saying look
i'm too old for this i can't i can't do
this that's pope
and yeah we're going to have a president
who still wants to be president in his
mid 80s
not tenable can't do it all right let's
get to our comment
[Music]
sloth
sections
well folks this is it he said a million
subscribers let's see that interpretive
dance matt well
i did say i'd do an interpretive dance
when we hit a million
but right now we're at one point i think
we're at 1.0
we're like at 1.03 million i think
so so we hit a million over the weekend
so technically like it's we're past that
point technically because now we're at a
different
we're not at a million anymore that's
what i'm trying to say
also i never said when the dance would
happen i didn't say that
so i'm not saying i'm not gonna do it
i'm just i'm just saying i never said
when i would do it
okay
if i look at the bylaws and the the fine
print i never said when
maybe i need to practice for 10 years
and we do it you know
maybe this is the way we ring in the
2030s
see
uh carsonian the great says matt this
isn't you've already talking about
uvalde isn't the biggest law enforcement
scandal of all time waco is that's true
also in texas of course and um
you're certainly when you look at the
body count and everything else else that
went into it you're you're probably
correct in that
but um
it's in the conversation
you've all the years
i don't think we've seen anything quite
like it before
and hopefully never again
um
fuzzy friends says as a life and
relationship coach every woman i've ever
talked to
secretly confided in me that they wanted
to nest slash nurture and that they
wished they could be a housewife
unfortunately the employment market is
so saturated men no longer earn an 80
000 per year salary with full benefits
for their family it now takes two
incomes of non or low benefit uh 35 000
a year jobs to survive women can't be
women anymore in today's world
well i don't want to disagree with a
life and relationship coach but i would
probably not every woman
secretly wants that but it is true
that this is a
natural desire that lots of women have
they want to settle down with a man they
want to you know they want to uh be um
keep up the
they want to be a homemaker
and
but it's shameful so you're not allowed
to talk about that just like if you're a
man and you want to have
a wife and you want to be the
breadwinner you want to care for your
kids and have that kind of quote
traditional life it's also it's
considered shameful now so you're not
allowed to talk about that either it's
another thing that makes
uh the dating world it's like reason
number one million why i'm so glad i'm
not in the dating world anymore
another thing that makes it impossible
is that people feel like they can't even
be honest about what their goals are
what they want out of life
uh yet another reason okay derek says i
have to argue a point
um
you're okay going after social media
platforms how is that different from
people suing gun companies for gun
violence well it's different because not
everything is the same
i don't know how else to put it not not
all things are analogous
some things are different from other
things
so a a gun is not the same thing as a
social media platform just like two
entirely different categories of things
is how i would explain it
um also when we talk about guns we're
we're talking about constitutional
rights our second amendment rights
so it's an entirely different category
and the other point is that when we talk
about going after social media platforms
the discussion last week was about
social media platforms and the way that
they
inflict real harm on kids in a very
intentional way
they're marketing themselves to like
young kids
okay gun gun manufacturers are not
marking themselves to 12 year olds
they're not allowed to do that they're
already not allowed to do that
social media platforms are
and um
they're doing it in a way to hook these
kids in
and why do they want to harm kids is it
because they're a bunch of like sinister
super villains and they want to harm
kids just for the sake of it maybe some
of them do but but mostly it's just
because it's money you get kids hooked
on the product
then uh that's a lot of money for you
and when you have generations of kids
who are hooked on the product whether
it's tick tock or any other social media
platform that's billions and millions of
dollars so there's a profit motive there
and uh i think that they
that uh
that's why we should hold them to
account
um
let's see gy says matt parents screw up
i know we did hindsight being 20 20 and
all that we thought we were doing
everything right we bought a limited
phone for our oldest daughter when she
was 13 because at that time she was
coming home from school and we would be
alone for two hours until i came home
from picking up my husband from work
he's now disabled we wanted to have gps
tracking in case something bad happened
and put very strong parental controls to
lock the internet and everything else
she broke through every single
restriction we put on the phone with
help from her friends her last phone a
few months ago we cancelled because the
tracking system didn't work and she
still managed to get around the no
internet thing by hacking the phone that
was supposed to not have access to data
at all now she has no phone at all and
she's 16 but the damage was already done
first musically now tick-tock between
that and the bullying she went through
when we finally put her in public school
and now we have a child who is
thoroughly depressed and questioning her
gender her teachers all support her
desire to be called max
every well-vetted therapist we've talked
to about uh cptsd
she has from bullying lies to our face
about supporting our viewers and makes
things worse it happened to us
conservative catholics like yourself we
did everything we could
do and we thought was right but the
culture is insidious and circumstances
can suck if we had known then what we
know now this would be a totally
different story i'm telling you now but
give us some grace here we don't deserve
it but we need it we've done everything
we can do we're another statistic well
i'm i'm uh
sorry to hear all that i mean this is
i've heard this story so many times and
it's always terrible
and it's terrifying for me also as a
parent of younger kids okay so they're
and i i've fully realized that and have
acknowledged it i think many times
that um
there are challenges to having younger
kids the challenges change as you as as
the kids get older but there are certain
aspects to this that we haven't had to
fully deal with yet um right now it's
pretty easy for our kids don't have
phones they've asked about it before and
we just say no you're not we're not
giving you a phone and we that's the end
of the discussion um it's gonna be a
little bit that's not gonna be as easy
as they get older we realize that
so grace giving grace to parents i do
give grace to parents
in fact in particular parents of
adolescent kids and teenagers especially
as what you're going through and
struggling through when a kid comes home
from school
and says oh i'm a different gender now
something they picked up this social
contagion thing that's completely
different in my mind from
the parents that we heard in the fox
news segment who said oh my two-year-old
chose their gender no that's you as a
parent doing that to your kid if they're
two or three or four or five
if your kid's 14 or 15 coming home from
school with this then that's that's you
could have done everything right or that
you thought was right you know trying
your best and now you have to deal with
this too so i totally understand that
but the point with the phone is you say
yourself if you've known
if you knew them what you know now you
would have made different choices and so
that's why i tried it that's why i'm
always hammering on this point about the
phones
i'm not saying it's always going to be
easy as kids get older to stop them from
using the phones
and if you give them a phone with the
parental locks kids are they're like
little ninjas when it comes to that kind
of thing
they're like little houdinis when it
comes to breaking around parental
controls
and that's why it's just you've got to
draw
for any parents who have not had to go
through this yet draw the line in the
sand
it's it's worth it
to avoid you know situations like this
so tomorrow june 14th it's the um
premiere of the daily wires next great
film terror on the prairie which i
personally have been looking forward to
as a big western fan you remember when
hollywood and disney tried to cancel
gina carano two days after ajina was
canceled daily wire announced that
they'd be that she would be starring in
and producing our next original film
and tomorrow june 14th you'll see the
fruit of all that labor we'll be
celebrating the premiere of her brand
new film with the daily wire terror on
the prayer tara the prairie is a gritty
western and genius personal redemption
story shines through in her leading role
she doesn't pull any punches as a
frontier woman fighting for survival in
the brutal american west uh i'm really
excited for everyone to see this film
i'm excited to see it myself it's a good
old-fashioned western without the
wokeness and we need more movies like
that i think in the world plus it's
produced by our friend dallas sonja who
brought you bone tomahawk with kurt
russell so you know it's going to be
gripping authentic it's going to have
some edge to it as well go to
dailywire.com gina and tune in tomorrow
at 8 30 pm eastern for the pre-show
9 p.m eastern for the world premiere of
the film and stick around for a q a
following the film head to dailywire.com
gina right now now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
you know rolling stone is not exactly
known for its journalistic integrity
this is after all the outlet that
published a rape hoax and uh once put
the boston bomber on its cover
now so i wasn't expecting exactly fair
or objective treatment when i found out
that they had wrote written about my
film what is a woman and it's clear in
the first sentence of their piece that
there is no pretense of actual
journalism here the author of the piece
moises mendes writes quote for years
right wing commentator daily wire host
and all-around provocateur matt walsh
has used his platform to go after trans
people so it's not surprising that this
essentialist ideology has become the
centerpiece of his new documentary what
is a woman now i take exception to this
on a number of levels first of all i am
not a provocateur i think i'm a pretty
decent provocateur so of course these
are you know ideal cultural conditions
for being a provocateur it's a bit of a
bull market for for uh provoking
considering you can provoke by simply
asking people to define words they're
using
it'd be a lot more difficult to be a
provocateur in a sane society i realize
that um that's not a challenge i have to
deal with though and you can't hold that
against me i'm just playing the hand i
was dealt here
anyway the real motive behind this
rolling stone piece becomes immediately
obvious the outlet
would seem to be at first sort of
breaking ranks with their corporate
media counterparts by actually
acknowledging that my film exists even
if only to dump on it
so why take this risk why risk giving me
more publicity
part of the reason is that nobody reads
rolling stone or even knows that it
still exists so the publicity factor is
negligible i'm sure that was that sort
of factored into their decision the
other reason is that they want to
pressure social media platforms to ban
me
going back to the article it says
now the daily wire has bought ads on
major social media platforms like tick
tock facebook and instagram to promote
the film and so far even though the
documentary seems to violate tiktok and
metta's policies against hate speech
though the platforms prohibit
dehumanizing mocking and or hateful
speech about transgender people the ads
have been allowed to stay
okay so this film is hate speech
it dehumanizes and mocks
don't just take rolling stone's word for
it they also spoke to glad
the activist the gay activist
organization and glad agrees quote
national lgbtq organization glad feels
that it's contradictory for these
platforms to allow these sorts of ads
especially during a time when they claim
to be uplifting and highlighting queer
content
social media companies are in the midst
of honoring pride month by loudly
sharing how they support lgbtq people
while simultaneously profiting off of
ads for a video project that is built
off of lies and misinformation about our
community these platforms can and must
do more to take action and enforce their
own rules regarding content that
violates their own standards of accuracy
and safety
oh it's unsafe content remember red flag
this is quite a rap sheet they've
compiled for my film the movie is
hateful dehumanizing
built off of lies and misinformation
it's so bad that we shouldn't be allowed
to advertise it on any major social
media platform
the writer moises must have you know
must have really watched the movie
closely and thought long and hard about
it before arriving at these damning
conclusions i mean these are some
serious indictments
i can't imagine the research that moses
must have poured into this
his editors also must have sat down and
really watched the film carefully and
you know uh if they're going to publish
something like this they sat down they
watched it
did a lot of research i assume
well maybe not see we we sent screeners
to rolling stone because we thought they
might be interested in writing about the
film turns out they were you know they
were interested in writing about it but
our mistake wasn't thinking that they
might want to watch the film
before writing about it
though moises mendes and his editor
elizabeth garber paul apparently didn't
realize this we could actually see
how much of the film was viewed on each
individual screener that we send out
which means that we can see clear as day
that the editor elizabeth garber paul um
she watched a whole 11 of the movie
before publishing this piece
and the author i mean the guy who
actually wrote this searing indictment
of what is a woman calling it
transphobic hateful misinformation etc
he watched exactly zero percent of the
movie
we can see that you see it right there
zero percent
he didn't watch one second of it before
offering his review of the work
moses mendes he's like a food critic who
walks by a restaurant
doesn't even go in glances through the
window
and then writes a detailed review
panning the food
now you might think that rolling stone
was aware that we would know they didn't
watch the film before reviewing it and
that perhaps they just didn't care you
know maybe they were defiantly flaunting
their own close-mindedness
but that theory is contradicted by the
fact that moises locked down his twitter
account within three minutes of me
publishing the screenshot showing that
he didn't watch the movie
rolling stone soon followed suit by
putting the article behind their paywall
um they clearly weren't planning on
getting called out and didn't think they
would be
that's a that's a theme consistent with
what you find in the movie itself if you
were to actually you know watch it
people on the left aren't prepared to be
held accountable and that's
somewhat understandable to be fair in
their privileged bubble
there is no accountability
they're not familiar with the concept
they don't know how to react when it
happens
now i'm not naive i know that nobody at
rolling stone is engaging in any
self-reflection today
i'm sure moises mendes did not even take
a second to pause and ask himself wait
am i nothing but a half-witted
propagandist
is that what i've become
he's not thinking about that
instead he's no doubt hiding behind his
locked account crying that all the scary
right-wingers are being mean to him
yet even if we cannot get these people
to ever look in the mirror
and see themselves for who and what they
are
we can at least see them more clearly
and we can know that they must never be
taken seriously
nothing they say means anything
they are not interested in truth or
accuracy or anything related to it
so we shouldn't be interested in
anything that they ever say
about anything
instead we should say to moises mendes
and all the moises mendez's of the world
you are all
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavovsky our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022.
nancy pelosi claims that transvestitism
is what america is all about fox news
fox news encourages parents to trans
their kids i'm not joking and justin
trudeau bans guns for self-defense in
canada check it out on the michael
knowles show